I think a lot of people that that
struggle with the beauty aspect of the
churches are people that look at let's
say the story of Christ and look at his
crucifixion they look at the the poverty
of the images in the gospel and so
they're like why then do you have these
golden temples and why do you have all
this powerful imagery and the truth is
that Orthodox Christianity tends towards
fullness tends to like a yes and right
we don't have a no but it's like yes and
and one of the images that's important
in scripture is the eschatological image
although Christ even in his life the way
that he lived very simply and walked you
know with sandals on the ground he also
presented this vision of the coming of
the son of man as this glorious finality
where all things will come
together
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic
[Applause]
world so hello everyone it is my great
joy to be here with uh David Patrick
Henry and father turbo this is something
that has been preparing itself for quite
a while I've been looking forward to
meeting father tro we've had a lot of
conversations know in in messaging and
email and stuff so it's great to finally
meet him in person and uh and so David
Patrick from the channel of the Church
of the Eternal logos so you can check
that out uh is going to lead the
conversation we're going to talk about
beauty about icons and so uh yeah take
it away David yeah I was really excited
thanks again Jonathan for having us on
uh when we talked a little bit about the
beauty of logos theology we mentioned
that you you had been wanting to stream
and have a conversation with Father
turbo and I have the great Fortune of
him being both a a spiritual father to
me and also a friend and um we wanted to
talk a little bit about Aesthetics
Orthodox Beauty iconography and all
these things and I thought it was
perfect for you guys to come together
because both of you have done
iconography and both of you you again
Jonathan with your work with the
symbolic world has touched on these
topics at nauseum I guess you could say
but um to begin just for father turbo I
thought he could kind of set the
foundation of how is Beauty and
Aesthetics under understood and utilized
in the Orthodox Church when Protestants
engage times they would uh make claims
that we're over ornate that we worship
pieces of wood that we you know we we
worship idols and all this different
stuff and they don't understand why
Aesthetics and beauty is important to
our liturgical worship to the church to
our Theology and how we uh engage and
participate with God and I so I thought
to open it up and we can go anywhere is
Father turbo could lay out exactly how
Aesthetics work and in the Greek Greek
word symbo Sim Balo throwing together
two realities that a symbol from an
orthodox worldview is so much more than
just a sort of an empty meaningless
thing as you've talked about Jonathan
but it's it's the bringing together of
two realities and so father if you could
then lead us into how Aesthetics are
understood from an orthodox fra well I
think the first thing to understand is
that it's about leading us into
reality which is God and the
incarnational aspect of it is absolutely
imperative but I think sometimes we stop
short because we'll look at an icon of
let's say you know this is very common
uh you give a tour in a temple and you
know every priest is done this every you
know lay lay leader has done this and
you kind of break down the iconas if
you're blessed to have a a a dome with a
Ponto icon in the dome you're blessed to
be able to you know have those not every
church has those unfortunately on on a
kind of like Majestic scale but you say
like oh you know Christ the Incarnation
and this is all very good you know but I
think it isn't just about the
Incarnation meaning the logos becoming
flesh um but it's also about us being
brought into the life of God and that
incarnational aspect you know think of
it going both ways I think is key
because worship is a about this bringing
in of the finite the
created the broken into you know
Infinity eternity into the you know
never actually reaching but being able
to be drawn and approach the uncreated
being broken and being brought to
Healing those are all things that you
know Aesthetics the Aesthetics of the
church facilitates it brings us to a
place of not just the abstract of
theology but the the real tangible which
is what we need to be healed to
experience love and symbol does all of
that in a shorthand you know I I try to
instruct people when they think about
symbol in the life of the church you
know it's it is imbued with something
higher than itself and so um when we
encounter a cross we can look at a cross
and you know a whole unfolding of
understanding happens you know in a mill
second so it's a shorthand that brings
us into increasingly deeper levels of
meaning and
experience um and that and it's really a
bringing in and I think that's really
key because when we view the icon or
when we view architecture in the church
when we um also you know it isn't just
visually when we experience chant you
know um there's something that happens
to you when you're in a service and then
you hear the E song you know the E song
is the kind of like low droning note for
those who don't know what that is
enchant and then just all of these you
know this this wave of of Melody that's
melismatic and it's just it's undulating
and it's just it's living and and it
brings you into this heavenly space
that's all a part of it and it's all a
part of being brought being drawn you
know invited into into God and so so
that's that's its purpose and it and
it's done in such a way to communicate
the ineffable to us that which is you
know beyond our normal way of being able
to articulate understand and that's what
I mean by layers of of meaning um and
really love and experience this is what
symbol does it's this you know however
you want to call it Bridge you know
um comic book fans will call it a boom
tuo I however you want to look at it it
just brings you to this place and that's
that's what it's always been and
especially for us now um in this modern
time it's it's even more so a rich
experience because we are inundated with
a plethora of images we're inundated
with a plethora of sounds and there's
something so um CLE it's cleansing it's
cathartic it's it's it brings us to this
this place um that I
think although we suffer in many ways
from lots of things that you know the
ancient people didn't have and the
ancient people where this aesthetic was
was formed through we have a unique
blessing in the sense that we can in
some ways um appreciate it on a
different level because we're coming
from a place of of absence we're coming
from a place of being you know like I
said inundated and it helps us to see
this one thing which is beauty is the
revelation of Christ and I think that's
you know the kind of period I would put
on it it's it is the revelation of
Christ and everything from you know
Harmony symmetry you know um and even
you know areas where there isn't
symmetry even those reveal Christ so
that's how I would explain it you know
well and I love that you talked about
the symbol is it bringing it into
ourselves because it connected with a
stream that we did on the devil's
iconography which is a famous quote of
Father s from R talking about
pornography but then through these black
mirrors our our phones that we're seeing
that especially those who aren't of
careful discernment spiritually that
they're they're bringing in demonic
iconography within themselves and it's
it's impure as you talked about a sort
of purifying effect of true beauty I
think we're also seeing an attack on
Aesthetics within our society at
multiple levels and this is affecting
the interior reality the spiritual
reality of people themselves I know this
something that Jonathan has spoke about
a little bit father tro I think he
really brought it all together maybe a
thing in terms of helping especially
Christians that don't understand why it
looks the way it does or why it is the
way it is in our church I think a lot of
people
that that struggle with the beauty
aspect of the churches are people that
look at they's say the story of Christ
and look at his crucifixion they look at
the the
poverty of the images and in the gospel
and how Christ lived a simple life you
know with fishermen and so they're like
why why then do you have these golden
temples and why do you have all this
powerful imagery and the truth is that
Orthodox Christianity
is tends towards fullness tends to like
a yes and right we don't have a no but
it's like yes and and one of the images
that's important in scripture is the
eschatological image that is the way
that although Christ even in his life
the way that he lived very simply and
walked you know with with sandals on the
on the ground he also presented this
vision of the coming of the son of man
as this glorious finality we all things
will come together and the glory of the
throne will be will be shown and you
know and the the the the authority and
the glory of God will fill the world
right you see that already in the
prophetic text even before the the
coming of Christ right that the glory of
God will fill the entire Earth and that
is what we are that is what we are
participating in in our church service
we are participating an eschatological
reality which is piercing in know
piercing in from the future piercing in
from the final Revelation and giving us
a glimpse of of how we can participate
in that glory and so many people they
like why are you doing this Old
Testament stuff like you know why are
you why are you still doing like the Old
Testament now that Jesus has come that's
changed but uh the image of the church
is not based on the Old Testament as
much as based on the Book of Revelation
and that's true even from the early
churches if you go to Rome and you see
the very early churches that were were
built in the 4th Century they have
eschatological Motif you know they they
they're representing the 24 elders and
you see you see Christ on the throne and
there's a sense in which that's what the
Liturgy has always been calling us to
participate in and so in some ways it's
the proper ordering of reality when you
read the the Heavenly Jerusalem you have
this beautiful vision of how
civilization how all the activities of
humans you know architecture music the
the relationship of the natural and the
artificial all of this is properly
ordered in glory to God and that is what
we that is what we're participating in
when we when we go to church and I think
that that's really important uh to
understand because the thing even in
terms of the idea of beauty and of
ornament and of proper ordering and all
this stuff these are all things that
exist also we have to understand it's
like one of the things that that happens
is that you know if you look at the the
the early Bond period for example when
people started criticizing the Christian
church and the excesses of the Christian
church all of a sudden all that ornament
and all that excess got put into stateb
built things right and so that ex that
desire to celebrate and to kind of lift
up and to make Beauty and to make even
like even to to to a certain excess is
something that's part of our of our
nature uh and if we don't dedicated to
God we're going to end up dedicating it
to something else and you're going to
start you're going to start with this is
how bad it is it's like you're going to
start with making government buildings
ornade and huge and beautiful and you're
G to end with some pop star looking like
decked out like Queen with gold and and
jewels and everything right that's how
you end and so you start you start with
you want to remove that Glory given to
God and you end up with like an image of
a kind of that that is completely
you know decked out and make up put uh
excessively ornamented right uh and so
we have to be able to direct our desire
for for that kind of exuberant Beauty in
the right in the right place yeah I
think you make a great point in regards
you you don't get away from the ornation
in society one way or another but it's
actually of a selflessness when we give
it back to the church when we give it
back to God and we give the as as as
much as we can do in a temporal setting
the beauty the Transcendent Beauty and I
wrote down Timeless objectivity because
as you pointed to the sort of
eschatological Dimension the piercing of
beauty inside of a parish or personal
relationships wherever people encounter
it insinuates the objectivity of beauty
the objectivity of morality and the
objectivity of the truth which is a who
not a what it's Jesus Christ he is truth
incarnate and so the ornation isn't
something that is paganistic or idolatry
it's actually actually something that we
want to give the best back to God and we
want to live in sort of that
Transcendent beauty that beautiful
reality and you look at Protestant
societies and as you said they don't
have saints so then Beyonce uh Johnny
Depp the Hollywood celebrities the Stars
Elevate themselves as now the the role
models the leaders for those in those
societies to look towards to orient
themselves in society and like you said
the ornamentation now is due to you know
these these modernist uh asymmetrical
art museums or these new understandings
of of beauty this is a displacement of
the lack of true Aesthetics within I
would say Protestant worship not that
there aren't great people of course
there are but you look at the the uh M
the mundaneness of many of the inside of
their churches I think that that that
that instinct and that Pursuit for
beauty then gets transposed to the world
and not back to God which is the
ultimate offering and I think that's
really key because the instinct is in
everyone and that's part of the problem
it has its points depending on you know
what we're talking about especially like
in a pical sense in regards of something
being Pagan or Christian but I I think
especially in this sense it's important
to realize that um you know why did why
do pagans you know what quote unquote
pagans right people little citizens you
know why why would they have Beauty
because it's it's innate in us because
God created us and the awareness this is
one of the things in regards of um
having a
disposition uh very much like what John
was saying about you know yes you know
and both and in the sense that you know
recognizing God as Creator and you know
God is and being able to see God in the
other person but also in their
expressions and even if they are devoid
of you know truth and
to a greater degree you know obviously
the truth and the awareness of who
Christ is you can still see the imprint
of God in that and and I think that's
really important because this idea that
when you know it's funny Jonathan said
that because it I had this I got
transported back in time I had a friend
I remember during my time of
conversion I think we were just made
cumans at the time and I had a good good
friend and I I invited her um to uh a
service and there was already contention
it's like what is this you know I heard
you're becoming Orthodox like what does
all this mean and I remember just her
you know kind of being in shock and and
on I remember especially you know the
great entrance happens um and then she
like got up and left you know she just
she got up and left in little C I was
like wow that's that's I don't know what
happened you know so I didn't you know
what's wrong you know and um after the
entrance I you know went to go talk with
her and she said you know Christ
wouldn't Christ wouldn't do all this and
I remember her saying that to me and I
remember feeling so sad not just because
my friend got up and walked out the
service but be but because this reality
that Christ is ruling and reigning
now that that's what made me sad because
I knew she loved God you know as and as
best as she could as what she understood
and that that is a very um
powerful thing to be able to recognize
the potential for people to experience
the god that already is you know kind of
imbued them with the desire and the
ability to pursue truth and beauty and I
think this goes all the way even back to
when we're talking about with like well
why you doing all this Old Testament
stuff well even that had the
eschatological reach even that was the
echo from Heaven even there and I think
this is really key because when people
set up this kind of dialectic of like
well well you do it this way do it that
way it it it's they lose this reality
that this is about
Revelation that although yes you know
certain aesthetic from a period of time
you know that we call quote unquote
Byzantine right but the reality is is
that those are just the means by which
God is
revealing himself to us and one of the
things that the church does through her
aesthetic is trains her trains her
people you know trains the people of God
to have an
increasingly
um astute accurate pure but expansive
view because we will never be able to
contain you know we'll forever be
approaching the fullness of God and so
if we find our vision becoming you know
more and more limited and circumscribed
we have to be careful that it isn't
really about um becoming more accurate
but maybe we are losing we're going in
the wrong way if that makes sense you
know because one of the things that you
learn when you enter into Orthodox
worship if you're not Orthodox is it's
incredibly familiar and Incredibly
foreign at the same time how is that
possible and that Paradox that tension
that's a very spiritual thing being able
to keep that tension and I think that's
one of the things about are being quote
unquote Orthodox in this modern time is
that we can see it's like another
example I remember taking uh one of my
kids to the bank for whatever reason
greatest greatest you know kind of
anecdotal story but you know my my
daughter she's like I think she was like
11 at the time she's like this looks
like a church right like the way the way
it was decorated you know it had this
you know it had a very um Art Deco feel
to it but Art Deco has this kind of very
Byzantine aesthetic baked into to it
right and so she could just discern that
naturally you know and I said well yeah
I told her I I told her this is a temple
but it's a temple to Mammon you know and
so we kind of had a little Bible story
there while we're waiting for the teller
but my point with these stories is that
it's it's already in people and and I
think for a lot of people outside of the
tradition you know in love it's this
this dialectic like well you guys just
kind of invented this and you just kind
of take this took this from the pagans
and it's like
okay even even that even that even if
that is the case um what you I think are
missing my friend is that God who
created all things this is this is the
revelation of how he's getting back to i
s earlier drawing us closer you know
yeah and but it's important to to
understand like you you you said about
this woman who said Christ wouldn't do
this you know and and when you talk
about the Paradox in the Orthodox
tradition we do have that Paradox very
strongly represented which is we both
have the aesthetic living in a cave you
know eating like carrots every day or
whatever for the for his entire life and
we also have you know Constantinople and
hagya Sophia and the the absolute Glory
of of of this eschatological vision and
the truth is that those two not only can
coexist but in some ways they reinforce
each other right it's like we if we only
had the the the great celebration and
the kind of Royal aspect of the
tradition we would we could you could
say that we would have something missing
but that's not how it is we we have and
you see it sometimes like you know you
you see it we pay attention to this if
if people who are careful you'll see
some priest like come to the parish you
know and you can see like his ratty
this ratty thing and and it's like you
he's got his hat and it's all fraying
and it's
like is like is like you know it's like
you can see and he's got he's got his
prayer rope that it's like it's kind of
slick from the oil of his fingers or
whatever right and it's like you know
you see the the the priest come in and
then and then he puts
on right the vestment and then he enters
into the worship and and part
participates in this glorious thing but
it's like that's the that's the contrast
you know and it's it's a very important
contrast to have it's as strong as the
contrast between the cross and the
Throne of Christ which are both true and
both re manifest the fullness of what
Christ brought to us uh and so it's
important to understand it even in terms
of what you said in terms of the city
for example like this idea of of
bringing in the Pagan elements into the
know the image that that we see in
Revelation is the image of the city
being converted right it's like the holy
city now becoming a vehicle and it says
in scripture in Revelation it talks
about the Heavenly Jerusalem it says the
kings of all Nations brought their Glory
into the Heavenly Jerusalem right and so
the glory of all the nations is brought
into the Heavenly Jerusalem so it means
that it's not it doesn't oppose that
which is good in all the cult cultures
in all in all the world it's rather that
the best of Rome the best of different
cultures can be brought in as an
offering to become a vehicle for a
participation in the Heavenly liturgy so
you both have this image that the the
image of the Liturgy is a representation
of the the the description in Revelation
of the angels that are surrounding the
throne and are sensing and and doing all
these things that that we do in church
but then also of the Heavenly Jerusalem
that which is happening on Earth as this
image of because a lot of the forms that
we have in church it's true they're
Roman right they come from Rome a lot of
the architecture a lot of the even some
of the vestments uh uh there are certain
things that have brought in from Rome
but that is the image in the Book of
Revelation right there's both there's
two RS you could say in Revelation
there's the which is the evil
aspect of the city the evil aspect of of
civilization that beast and that
together but then there's also this
other image of all of human activities
bringing up their glory in service of
God yeah you speak go ahead father I
just want to say I think it's important
too to kind of
like dive you know kind of drop down a
couple thousand feet and even just
looking at the fact that the quote
unquote again Byzantine right Roman the
aesthetic even that is a
synthesis you know when we when we
experience it it it isn't just this kind
of pure aesthetic just that popped out
of any where it doesn't have you know
influences from different nations I mean
what Jonathan just brought up about the
eological aspect I mean works I think
what I'm what I'm failing at trying to
get across too is that that you we're
experiencing that now to a veil degree
or whatever you however you would put it
because even in regards of the aesthetic
of the church there are these sematic
influences Asian influen Persian
influences and you know this is one this
is one of the things that when you see
that already you're already seeing it if
you see what I did right there like
you're already seeing it happen and I
think this is really key
because one of the big problems when we
Veer too far one way with something is
that we we we miss some of the details
that are very important like for
instance one of the things that I you
know I don't do them as much but I used
to do lectures and iconography like a
lot and one of the things that I would
do that would just you know kind of
scandalize people I would talk to them
about fume portraits F portraiture and I
mean it without fail especially at that
time this isn't like the like mid like
2005 2006 2007 and I would you know do
these slideshows and I'd show them and I
talk well you know the about the origins
of the quote unquote Byzantine style you
know quote unquote and you know some
people would start getting kind of
uncomfortable you could see it in their
eyes because they have this idea that it
just kind of like drops out of nowhere
Drops Out of Heaven yeah you know what I
mean and and it doesn't and it it it is
this which God always does right God
takes the synthesis of of human failed
yes and Fallen yes but but human effort
Human Experience and he wields it
together he baptized it he purifies it
he illumin it he imbus it with his love
with his presence that's what the love
of God is it's his presence if God
shines his presence on you it's because
he loves you how you how you respond to
that that's a different thing but it's
it's always out of his love and we see
that
Revelation is a very unitive one of the
effects of the revelation of God is it's
unitive it brings it brings synthesis it
brings things together because that is
the repentance that's the undoing of the
Fall that dis that dis unification on a
lot of levels it's taking seemingly
disperate parts and bringing them into
Harmony and I think that's one of the
things that maybe should be emphasized a
little bit more because as the world you
know and I mean it like the world like
the passions you know In the Flesh and
the Fallen World and all that and and
the Fallen powers are are continually
seeking
to imitate to even greater and greater
degree um the life of the church and and
the the glory of God for the sake of
deception and all these things it's
important that we discern that you know
ultimately you know the love of God is
is what could never be um triumphed over
and that love it it conquers you know
love covers a multitude of sins but in
this sense the the the problematic
multiplicity which Jonathan has talked
about at you know at death and at nause
but that problematic multiplicity of
culture and and all those things it it
really does get reconciled in the church
I mean St John the Baptist the holy
mother of God always on the iconostas I
mean right male female the aesthetic the
Heavenly Queen like right there it's
it's always there for us to see Andrew
ghoul the architect has pointed out to
what extent hagya sopia is Persian like
that that even in like the sixth
Century uh they have a Roman building
it's still a Roman building clearly it
and but that a lot of the ornamentation
was brought in from Persia and there
seems to have been this this desire like
you said to to bring in things and to
join them in synthesis it's like it's
the opposite of mixture it's the
opposite of confusion right confusion is
when disperate things don't play
together towards a common goal that's
when you have confusion so you have a
bunch of different things and they're
doing their own thing and they're not
coming together towards towards towards
purpose whereas uh synthesis is when you
do have several things but they're all
let's say kind of dancing together and
you can feel that they're joining uh
towards a common a common purpose and so
Christians are
not how can I say this like Christians
are not against or for diversity and and
against against the idea of different
things it's
rather how is it that they come together
in love in participation in the Life of
Christ that's all really that matters
you know and and the Liturgy ultimately
plays that that that great role like you
said like if you look at the iconostasis
and even the way in which we we are like
we are the people you know saying the
amen there's the choir there's the
there's the there are the priests and
the clergy and there's all these
elements and they're all they're all in
a great dance you know they're all
coming together in the worship of God
well and I wanted to pick up on a
comment that you said a few ago in
regards to the tension between Beauty
and aestheticism Jonathan and I think
that we look at the contemporary culture
and I totally agree with you that's what
the church does it holds the both and
together and I when you're talking what
popped in my mind is that the growth in
uh Hedonism and pleasure seeking
actually erodes the beautiful tension
and distinction between Beauty and
asceticism and as we become more
hedonistic one we can look at the
informal of our society I mean it's
stark contrast to look at the beginning
of the 20th century on how the average
person dressed verse in the beginning of
the 21st century and again the the
informal of the way we dress the
informal of the way we talk to each
other but maintaining boundaries
something that I kind of reap on a lot
and harp on a lot on my channel is that
this is the point of the logos is that
it maintains the order it maintains the
boundaries between things and that I
would argue moving forward at least what
we're seeing in culture is this
continual dissolution of boundaries and
distinctions between things and so as
formalism breaks down as boundaries
break down you're talking about how
discipline is tied to the coming uh of a
forward purpose well we're living in a
culture where discipline is under the
under attack essentially meritocracy is
under attack that we have new
understandings of the way that we move
through uh our societies and that beauty
and asceticism are necessary because if
you just have Beauty you're going to end
up in Hedonism you're going to end up in
in
overindulgence which we could look at
the Roman Empire we can look at the
American Empire we can look at our own
context and culture and so I think again
the the church what it does is it holds
these things in the proper context and
that beauty is true and beauty is
morally right and morality is true and
beautiful and that all the the good true
and the Beautiful they play on each
other and I think pleasure in the per in
the lack of the crucifying of our own
will is actually leading to the eroding
of all these things in our society to
one degree or another and you you'll see
it's interesting because you know that
image that I proposed at the at at some
point when I talked about the priest
that comes in you know kind
of you know a little ratty and a little
kind of disheveled or whatever and then
and then moves into the glory uh there's
a sense in which the contemporary
culture is the very opposite of that
right it's like in some ways the church
asks you to come to church broken right
it's like come broken my friend like you
know come in confession come in come
contrite come not not like this you know
it's like come broken and if you come
broken then you get this Glory you get
to participate in this beauty and this
glory and the Contemporary world says go
out and like enjoy right do it do it all
like enjoy and and get participate in
excess and the result is that you are
accidentally broken right you're not
broken in the Christian sense of
recognizing your loneliness and entering
into that but you're made low and then
you suffer for it right you're you're
broken
and your relationships are broken and
everything gets broken so it's like a
weird inversion and a caricature of each
other like if I could if I could just
throw something out there though I mean
I think that so with Hedonism there's
something that happens in the sense that
you know Hedonism and it pulls it not
only pulls someone out of the potential
for that experience right but it
perverts intentionally in in in many
ways I would I would submit because
when you begin to you like for
instance the inability to see the
beauty in the aesthetic the inab the
inability to see the beauty that is in
in the poor right the the inability to
see the beauty that is in those things
that are not pleasurable right and I
think that's the thing is our society
conflates
Beauty with you know something that is
dazzling or pretty or it's not when when
the church speaks of beauty and I think
this is one the things when the church
speaks of beauty people can mistake it
for simply just you know that which is
grand um and you know that which elegant
is is a is a good way and a better way I
think in many ways to begin to explain
to people um what the how what beauty is
because Elegance can often times be very
subtle um the sublime is another way
because you know the sublime and and um
there is a
um at times this catching of the breath
at the sublime you know this this
landscape which is terrifying you know
in its beauty this I think this is
important because our culture seeks to
pull all that away and just give people
you know the sugar you know the the hot
pink you know what I mean and the ice
and and and you know and The Bling but
that's not Beauty anyways like there's
nothing beautiful really about that it
lacks Transcendence it lacks
Transcendence because because of it's
but it's it's absence what and what
makes it Transcendent is that
Transcendent isn't isn't a disdaining of
the whole but it something that's truly
Transcendent not only in cap ulates but
its ability to encapsulate it it moves
above it it's above it not doesn't
disdain it per se it's above it it's
it's beyond it right is's another way to
I think to see it and so I think this is
really key
because what could happen is that
someone could begin to see the beauty of
the church and if they don't allow the
beauty of the church to do its work they
could very be they could very easily
begin to lose the ability to see the
beauty of the church what I'm saying
because if you are coming in and if you
see beauty and you see only the aspects
of the beauty of the church which are
self-serving right order is self-
serving right we see it right all these
things are self- serving because we want
to be safe we want to be secure all
those things but you you'll begin to
miss it because then you're you are
extracting um because of your own desire
for Comfort to have those things which
you're only titilating and appeasing to
you right but the reality is is Christ
calls us into especially he gives us
eyes to see where the beauty is found in
the aesthetic in the beggar I mean if
you think about
Christ the logos incarnate walking among
men walking in the height of
civilization the Roman Empire that's
that's the height of civil civilization
on the planet right quote
unquote and he's pulling together like
and how does he do it like talking to
the Samaritan woman and he's talking you
know to these and he's he's doing all
these things alluding to the coming of
the Gentiles and his his Apostles they
bring in the Gentiles I mean all of this
is just it's mindboggling but that's
absolutely what Christ did in his
ministry was to show where there isn't
anywhere where he didn't touch right I
think that's really important for us
because if we lose that sense and people
can lose it especially especially as
people see the beauty of the church as a
beacon of of and it is a beacon of
safety but if it's always just that then
there are these places where Christ is
calling you and you will not be able to
see them because they're not things that
he's forcing upon you they're things
that he's inviting us into and I think
this is why the aesthetic tradition in
the
church isn't just about you know the
frustration in the body experience but
the icon for us in a modern time imposes
a fast on us in ways that I don't think
people understand you know that the icon
imposes a fast on our senses and calls
us to really reject the sugar and the
pop and the you know the the kind of you
know visual kinetic energy that's given
to us like all those things is it it
calls us to to
actually discern that the the pop and
the twinkle and the hot pink
isn't really
beautiful and you need to have the
bitter herb you need to have the salt
you need to have those things to really
help you to to apprehend that greater
scope of beauty right I think that I
think that's really key because if we
don't have that then what can happen is
people no longer are entering
into the Heavenly realm and they do just
make it you know a place which is like a
museum with gold you know ornamentation
and they and they begin to lose what the
icon of St John the Baptist is
communicating they they begin to lose
the sense of what the church is is
ushering us into and then it really does
become flat and two-dimensional in the
wrong ways and we lose the ability to
enter into that ecological experience
because now we're just you know
spectating on some sort of very um
interesting and exotic kind of amalgam
you know and that's that's not what's
happening you know right yeah I would I
would argue that the lack of Beauty in
our society coinciding with what you're
saying it's bringing us down to more of
a base level of reality and just the
pursuit of our Pleasures because what
what does in in 2023 walking through
America what gives somebody the sense of
all I mean is it the Empire State
Building like what exact bring somebody
to a Transcendent awareness of asking
deeper questions about themselves about
the world about each other um and that's
Again part of the as Jonathan
highlighted the eschatological purpose
of Beauty in itself of Aesthetics and
how God is working through the beautiful
to reach us directly
yeah and think about your saying father
tobo and and my question would because
there is that like in the the in the
Church there there is
definitely what modern people now would
call the The Bling right that is if you
look at the mosaics you know that are
that we still see in Rena or you know in
the in in hagya Sofia it's like it's
something I mean it is over the top you
know and then even the vestments right
the vestments Are Over the Top like hand
embroidered you know with gold thread
and and all that and so um How do you
you see that like how do you see because
I I kind of saw you pulling back and
saying we have to be careful not to be
also deceived by by that that that those
moving pictures or that kind of kind of
excess of luxury um and I mean I see
that in the tradition right I I see it
you know the you see it in St John Chris
system who in some ways is kind of
criticizing you know the the overly
overly ornamented Altar and then ends
and says but if there is gold you know
you should you should use the goal but
it's like you should be careful and it
reminds me also of the the patriarch of
Constantinople when jinian built hagya
sopia there's a legend the story I don't
know if it's true but there's a legend
that that he wanted to make the the
templon or the door I think it was the
door of the church out of gold or the
templon out of gold or something like
that like there was something some
massive thing in the church he wanted to
make out of gold and the patriarch said
he said okay you can do it but if
there's one beggar left in in antin ople
after that it's like that's on you right
that's on that's on you and so he kind
of had to pull back you know and make it
out of silver or something to kind of
find that balance and so how do you see
that because I mean I'm not a pastor so
I don't have to deal with that as much
but how do you see that even in in
managing a parish for example how to
balance the charitable aspect with the
beautification with the the you know the
the the the two kind of the tension that
you seem to be wanting to to bring up to
be careful not to be also seduced by
just this kind of external beauty yeah I
mean I I think um the first thing is
it's I'll just give this this Insight I
I hope this is helpful you know our
parish is in Kansas City and it's you
know in the middle of the hood you know
like the hood and when we were you know
it's a old uh Baptist Church which we
brought down to the studs and then you
know renovated
and when we were doing
it um you know I was being very
particular about things and there was
you know murmurs and some people that
were upset U they're no longer in the
community God bless them but they were
upset because they said you know why why
would you be spending all this you know
why you going to put a baptismal font
here why are you going to have a marble
inlay here why are you doing that and
then I sat down and I I told one of them
the story of you know the baptism of
Rose you know and the whole story of
like sending out the emissaries St
Vladimir sending the emissaries out to
you know all these places and you know
we all know the story right the missies
went here there and they finally went to
AIO and they're like we didn't know if
we were in Heaven and Earth and that
revelation of beauty wasn't just about
you know the the the incredible mosaics
in aguia at the time it was it was
chanting it was the music it was it was
the spirit that that was em bibed in the
people and we know that it's if you know
that it's valid because when you look at
the life of St Vladimir I mean he he
ceases being a polygamist he ceases
being cruel all these things begin to
affect him and begin to affect the
Russian people who were illiterate and
Pagan and barbarus and all that stuff
right and then they became people of God
now I say all that to say this the
reality is that
you know Beauty will save the word but
you have to know what beauty is first
and that's part of I think what the
church does is the church always you
know it's the it's the the yes and you
know it's the fullness it's we
maximalist but we also understand that
there is a a place where you must ascend
from excuse me you know you must you
must ascend from this place and the way
that I I think you really begin to do
this for someone is you begin to
understand what's your intent because
the intent if it's of the worship of God
and the worship of God necessitates the
bringing of the lost sheep then what
happens is there's a real sense of um
invitation that's in there
and I want to make this not so abstract
I think that there are moments in
people's lives when they can if you've
been Orthodox or non-orthodox you've
traveled around like why is it that you
can get a sense of something a warmth of
a
community um and it may not have all the
quote unquote acont that like a huge
perfect Parish has but you feel like
you're being ushered into the Orthodox
Church you feel like you're being
ushered into something that's just as
valid why is that well it's because of
the the
beauty the the actual material of that's
used to express the beauty is precisely
that it's just the material to express
the beauty um dph has behind him an icon
of St Maximus it's right there I was
just looking at it right and it's like
well the problem is that people have
these passions and they become attached
to things in a disordered improper
idolatrous way right it's like St
Maximus is famous is saying it's like
you know gold is an object woman is an
object right but gold connected to a
thought of luxury which is fundamentally
about self right then becomes a passion
you know it becomes this thing that
becomes idolatrous and so I think the
way I would say this is number one I
recognize that it is possible for
someone to become unduly enamored and
therefore you know begin to fall into an
idolatrous relation to the expression of
Beauty in the church church and we see
that when they begin to this is what St
John chrs is talking about when they
begin to disdain the beauty of Christ in
the beggar or whatever whatever context
that you want you want to look at but
ultimately that horizontal you know the
vertical of the Cross right you do the
cross you have the vertical of me seeing
God me seeing the Transcendent you know
me seeing all these things right and
ultimately it's still about me right
seeing that thing and being connected
but then if we begin to lose the
horizontal of that reality which is The
Humbling aspect of seeing the other and
seeing the beauty in the other I think
that's where people begin to lose it and
that's where you see people feeling like
it's not even so much that this person's
you know disturbing you but if they come
in it's like oh do they look unkempt you
know like that that happens in parishes
and I think that's I think that's
important because a parish which you
know someone I'm not talking again about
someone who's you know maybe having some
some mental health issues whatever I'm
talking about just if a if a human being
wanders in doesn't know what they're
doing but maybe I know this is crazy to
someone maybe God is leading them to to
that church to see something so that
they could have a place of conversion
and people could flip out and be like
hey you know gota get that guy out of
here right and St Peter talks about this
about hey be careful about having you
know the wealthy person brought to the
front and the poor person bought brought
to the back and I I think that is really
key because if we don't acknowledge and
we if we don't have the humility to
admit that we we could become beguiled
it's not the fault and that's that's
where I think a lot of the Protestants
evangelicals miss it is that they think
a person they realize that that can
happen but they think it's the fault of
the icon or the fault of the Mosaic it's
not the fault of the Mosaic or the icon
it's it's the person who has not kept
that tension of you know the
transcendent Beauty yes but also the
beauty that's that's humble you know the
beauty of of of the beggar St John C
yeah I mean and father turbo you can you
can treat the Bible as an idol too
absolutely that's not hard at all like
I've seen people do it all the time when
you talk to someone and they're seing
about the word of God the word of God
the word of God and you're
like what are you talking about and it's
like it's like it's like it's not Christ
the Incarnate logos it's the Bible
That's the only word of God and you're
like really I don't know it's a little
weird man it's the spell book they have
and they treat it like it's a spell book
you know right and so so yeah I mean it
is let's say any this is the this is the
you know I've been looking at Exodus a
lot because we did this Exodus seminar
you know a while ago and I've been
thinking a lot about some of the images
in the book and
um the the the the character of Aaron is
a really interesting figure because in
some ways a Aaron is a tool that God
gives to Moses to communicate to the
people because Moses is like I can't
communicate I need something so God
gives him an external he's like here's
this other layer that you can that that
will now speak for you and will be like
your representative in front of the
people and so he's like he is in some
ways that tool that God uses to manifest
himself but then he's the one who makes
the golden calf it's like that's the
duality of of externalization that in
some ways it's necessary and inevitable
that is all things that come down to to
us from God you know are externals in
the sense that there you know the
glories of God appearing in the myriads
of things that we that we see and that's
real and that's true but they are all
everything in the world is in danger of
becoming an idol if we are not looking
through them towards towards that which
is transcendent so it's just the reality
of external so and the idea that in some
ways uh our particular form of worship
is more endangered of becoming an idol I
think is nonsense it's it's just the
reality of of the externals uh yeah yeah
I was wonder if maybe we can tie a few
of the different topics we've discussed
with we're talking about symbols
bringing them into ourselves this this
Timeless Beauty the eschatological
importance of these things with us being
living icons because it seems that in a
sense that's what father turbo was
getting at in regards to me and my
relationship to the Transcendent but
then the horizontal is me enacting out
the beauty as a living icon of Christ
and that this is the goal of all of us
and this is the beautiful transformation
of all of us through theosis through the
engaging with these uncreated energies
of God I was thinking maybe father you
could speak a little bit to what what
for those who may not be familiar with
uh Windows of veneration how we
understand icons how does that relate
then to the individual person having
that relationship with Christ and
becoming a living icon well I think this
is one of the things that's really
important is because
um man you know I don't know if I can
talk without throwing something out
there that might be you know kind of
hard to swallow but I I
just there is no Christianity without an
aesthetic aspect it's just it it's just
you can't have it it's a it's a
caricature it's a
distortion and the reason why I'm saying
that is because the aesthetical aspect
of the life of the
church it's there to do it's there to
it's it's there to help keep this
tension that we're talking about right
and it's also there because that
tension's necessary in the sense of
development like if we're going to look
at the powers of the soul and the need
for the powers of the soul to be you
know honed and strengthened and
disciplined and the powers of the Soul
being primarily the means by which we
actually experience you know the Unseen
God right because God is the maker you
know the father's maker of all things
visible and invisible
and so that reality which is a reality
just because people are unaware of it
doesn't mean that that reality isn't
there and what the church does
especially for us is it wakens us up to
this reality and it does it through the
athetic tradition but it does it also
first and foremost I think through the
iconography through the beauty of the
church the architecture of the church
through the the beauty of our hypography
and our chance and the reason why I say
that is because what happens is when you
even if you are not aware of you know
the kind of the historical you know um
accidents of what different cultural
aspects brought together this thing when
you encounter it even if actually let me
flip that actually forgive me let me
flip that because oftentimes the the the
movie producer and the director is the
guy who can't watch a movie anymore
because he's he's so aware of what went
in there that he's no longer able to
kind of like suspend his knowledge to
actually enter into watching a movie you
know what I mean it's like the artist
who can no longer
appreciate something in in the way that
he used to back in the day because you
know he's he's become to some degree
like so Jaded by his knowledge right I
think what I'm trying to get at here is
that this reality when you experience
something and it's sometimes often just
a
Flash and it pulls you
to I don't have a better word except for
potential you maybe might be able to say
hope but you you get this flash of
something out it's otherworldly and and
I don't it's nothing that I that you
give an image to I'm not talking about
seeing flying you know horses or
anything like that I'm talking about um
a hope it's forgive me let me digress a
little bit
if you've ever experienced something
very tragic like the death of a loved
one or you know I see this whole time
being a priest ministering someone where
I'm with someone who's dying or they
know that their parent is dying or you
know something
really difficult is
happening and my my job my my work is
not so much to bring them to this place
where they can like kind of make it
through through um that's really up to
God in many ways and up to them but my
work is to be present with them just
being present because my presence is
only POS my presence is valuable in so
far as I'm trying to just be present to
Bear witness of what they're going
through and God willing to bring to be
some sort of conduit for Hope right and
that flash of Hope in the face of the
imminent
this I'm trying to describe what this
these flashes of Eternity these flashes
of something Transcendent in the real
way that's what if you if you're being
guided well and you're actually not just
looking at the icon and the church and
all these things is trying to you know
find a solid ground in a temporal sense
meaning like yes our society's crumbling
yes our political systems crumbling yes
our morality is crumbling all that but
like it's always crumbled Byzantium
crumbled you know quote unquote holy
Russia crumbled like what has kept the
people of God grounded it's these things
and it's actually in the face of these
very terrible moments that like we get
to see that hope being purified and to
some degree not purified but freed from
these things that were at once they're
given to us as
AIDS but we we want to hold on to the
crutches to some degree and I know this
gets into dicey territory because people
are like whoa whoa whoa father then
that's isn't that the isn't that the
mindset of like you know the Puritans
and all these people and I'm
like yes to some degree but it was again
not for the reasons that I'm talking
about because we can talk about all of
the I can give the legend to how to read
icons right this means this and this
means that and someone can become really
Adept at being able to break down like
oh this symbol means this this equals
this but see what what what they what
you don't understand and this only comes
from like really kind of experience and
striving for it is if the more Adept you
get at being able to kind of like read
the code the easier it is for you to
begin to miss it because what happens is
is you're now leaning into your ability
to wield understanding and information
for the sake of wielding it right and
that's magic that's not that's not what
this is about this is
about being brought to this place that
only God can bring us to that's what the
icons there for the icon is there to
sure on a real basic level even though
this isn't the case but there's truth to
it right that the icon is there
initially to you know pedagogically
instruct those who couldn't read but
that's not really you hear this but
that's not really the case
because it's like
we we are retrofitting our understanding
of how people learn in pedagogy and
experience on the Ancients right it
isn't just about reading right it's the
gospel is meant to be heard see people
that's not satisfying to people when
they hear well they the go gospel being
mean to heard no no because if I can
read it's meant to be read because yes
it is meant to be read but not not just
exclusively right because communal
activity it's a communal activity and
and not just communal in regards of like
the horizontal right but think about I
think about the children who hear the
gospel you know week in week out week in
week out and some of them are not gonna
many most of them are not going to go on
to be priests they're not going to go on
to be you know quote unquote Church
workers but they're gonna be plumbers
they're goingon to be moms and dads and
they may not even be picking up the
Bible daily although I hope they do but
something there's a seed that was
planted deeply in them
hearing those the hearing the
gospel there's there's something that's
very powerful that's opened up to them
when it may not even be a well executed
icon quote
unquote but what is it they'll remember
that icon that was in their church when
they're growing up why because the icon
facilitated something called communion
called connection and and that's the
thing is if if we don't kind of really
keep that I think
in the front of these
conversations it becomes very easy for
someone from outside of our tradition or
anywhere else to like oh that's cool and
learn this and that's where that's where
you get people who are like yeah yeah I
know about icons and it's cool and blah
blah blah blah blah and I have one here
right and they they're they're treating
it
like like it's a saeson print that they
got at Big Lots or something you know
what I mean it's a commodity it's a
commodity and and the reality of it is
is that
yes there is a whole thing about you
know inverse perspective and we can talk
about all these things and we should I'm
not saying we shouldn't but I think
what's I think what's appealing and
what's captivating for people is
that for instance why do people keep
listening to Jonathan because Jonathan's
a wealth of knowledge but I think the
thing about Jonathan is you still get
the sense that he's in awe and wonder
still you don't get the sense forgive me
for talking like you're not there
Jonathan like he doesn't you know he
doesn't it isn't just kind of like he's
just throwing like yeah d d d and this
is this and this is that right that you
can
tell to some degree that he's still
searching that he's still being pulled
into that he's still he's in communion
with
someone that's what we're that's what we
wna that's the Engle we don't want to
just know like the why of something but
it's like what you're saying DP about
like The Who and and I think if I I I
really think that's important to bring
forward
because one of the hardest things for
someone who's coming out of let's say a
reformed tradition uh an Evangelical
tradition is that they they see the icon
they see the Liturgy they see all the
mystery of the church and they want to
pierce that
mystery but the thing is is they have to
understand you can't Pierce that mystery
in the same way forgive for being lude
but you can't approach it the same way a
guy kind of wants to you know go for the
hunt you know what I mean like some guys
like the Chase and they they they you
want to you don't want to approach it
like you're you're gonna conquer
something and I think that's what
happens when we view these things in
just almost exclusively like kind of
pedagogical like approach we have to
remember like what like what is being
revealed here about who yeah I think I
think father Turbo what you're saying
what you're getting to is important in
terms even in terms of the question that
you asked there uh David that you know
the the one of the main purposes of the
icons is to bring into remind us of the
communion of the Saints in which we're
participating when we are in prayer and
in liturgy and so that's why we have
these standing saints that are just
there kind of standing in the church
like as if they're standing with us and
they're worshiping God and you know we
you know you talked also you you asked a
bit about how how we treat each other in
terms of the in terms of becoming icons
and that is something that I I I this is
a speculation on my part but I think
part of the reason why we kiss icons has
to do with the St Paul's uh asking us to
greet each other with a holy kiss I
think I think that there's at least part
of it which comes from that which is in
the same way that I bow to the priest
and kiss his hand the same way that the
priest comes out of the altar bows to us
and asks for forgiveness in that in that
way in which we receive Christ in each
other in the church and we and we
signify that through different ways in
the same way that we encounter the icons
and the Saints as a
continuation of the same process that
that we encounter each other with and so
I think you're right that there is a
connection definite Connection in the
manner in which we are meant to
encounter each other as icons
it's more I think it's more best
formulated not that we're to become
icons that's I that's difficult it's
like it's more that we should encounter
others as icons like we should when we
meet others we should see in them Christ
that should be our focus and if we do
that then we will be becoming like
Christ if we do that but to have to be
in that disposition where we see like
this person in front of me you know is
is is a is a little Christ to me and I
should I should I should treat him that
way that's hard that's a tough one but
that's what we're asked to do I very
early on when even you know just coming
to the church and people were like okay
what's this what's that blah
blah and I would explain to
them uh about my time um when I was uh
in the Balkans or even in Iraq and I'd
say look you know like I was missing my
wife and at the time two kids and I'd
pick up the picture I'd kiss it I I
would do that I'd be on the fob and I'd
be you know missing my missing my wife
and my kids and i' kiss the picture and
people would go like yeah they get it
they would get it because they've had
something some kind of experience
somewhat like that and they go like
there you go we can move past that if
you want and you know I can talk to you
about Fus kto and all that stuff but
like that's not going to get you
anywhere right now like what you want to
know is like okay like well how's this
helping
out how's this helping out the person
actually in the church not just the
priest you know not just the educator
but what about that kid what about that
old grandma what about working class gym
with his family I mean I'm really into
this because I I think one of the things
is that for for for the people the Leos
for the people it it's all there to
bring them into it because they're
they're the people of God it isn't just
about the educated and
the illumination that the church brings
comes from love it comes from Love and
and when we begin to have like that's
the thing
people have relationships with these
Saints they really do like if someone
you know it's like I'm in the Serbian
Church and the tradition of the Slava
and you know you have this patron of a
family and often times you know
generationally like they turn to St John
when there's actual problems St John
isn't just like we have St John up here
because he is a figurehead of resistance
to government power like that is such an
interpretation we would we would give
which it's valid I mean I'll I'll go
there all day I'll go there all day but
I think what's really important is that
not everyone should strive to be a
Jonathan Pou a David Patrick Henry like
I think people need to strive to be good
Faithful Men Who work their agback job
who go to church and love their neighbor
and when they do that they'll be able to
experience the glory and the profundity
of God like that's that's reality and
and I I'm all for that because that's
what transfigures the world right if we
have more forgive me forgive me I mean
as you move into the in the life of the
church then all of a sudden you know
like you said at some point you realize
that the Saints are there they're there
and you know if you're if you're
attentive to it you'll see see them kind
of you know act in your in your life and
act in the life of others and you know
that's a that's a great joy because it
reminds us that they're alive in Christ
you know and that they they're they're
they are still in the church and they
still pray for us and that just like
we're meant to pray for each other we
can kind of experience it when we see
the Saints move Among Us and and move
things you know Among Us so it's a it's
a testimony to what the church is yeah
forgive I just want this one thing I
tell people about and and I know it's
I'm taking Liberty with it but when I
get my explanations you
know I tell people the think of the Halo
in the icon as the wedding ring and the
the unification of God and and that
person right there's your theosis right
the unification of God and that person
and that wedding ring which is a symbol
right I mean and then you can even have
someone touch their wedding ring it's
like you know put your hand on that
wedding ring Jim you know put your hand
on that wedding ring you know Joanie and
recognize like what is that yeah that's
metal yeah that's gold yeah that's an
ore but like the effort that you put in
Jim to work those extra hours you know
to get Joanie that really nice ring
right that that's an actual
manifestation of your love for Joanie
and your love of you know Mark and Lucy
who are your parents right because
you're holding to this tradition and
you're you're loving this tradition and
you're giving of yourself in the real
world right Blood Sweat and Tears to
bring forth that love which is
immaterial in the sense of you know it's
invisible but we're you're you're
manifesting it and that's a real thing
and that's what icons are icons are a
window to Heaven okay well what's Heaven
well look at an icon ion and what's in
an icon every icon generally speaking
there's going to be a human
person right and a
Halo there you go God and man that's
what heaven heaven is the union of God
and man right anything else we begin to
kind of like get into other stuff but we
know that's what heaven is persons with
God and God in persons that's what it is
that's what the Kingdom of Heaven is and
so when we be when we're able to bring
it down to that level
and show you know Joanie and Jim that
the symbols that are even on their body
on their ring finger can actually lead
them into that understanding then you
start to approximate the purpose and the
function of the icon isn't just there to
give you you know a high level
theological understanding of you know
blah blah blah but it's actually like to
ground you which is incarnational like
that's the thing is that being
incarnational is about being
grounded and and I think this is really
key because
one of the big things that you want to
do that I wanted to do is I wanted to
pass
on the tradition yes but the life of the
church to my
kids right I want them to become
citizens because this is the meta the
church is the meta culture right
everything gets sub you know everything
is subsumed into that meta culture and
if there's something valuable and good
it gets baptized it gets illuminated it
gets you know impregnated with with
God's wisdom and glory and then it
becomes something blessed right and
that's that's why we have to keep this
reality in front of people and that
that's what the icon does it keeps that
reality of what God is calling and has
already ushered you into you know yeah
you remind me of the conversation I had
with Bishop Max ma uh Maximus on uh
participatory versus propositional
understandings of God and how we relate
and that this is what we're hinting at
through the entire ation was this
participation in God participation in
the experience of beauty the creation of
beauty uh participation in the uncreated
energies of God which is related to all
this different stuff so we're talking
about Saints we're talking about men
that with their free will chose to
choose God chose to love chose to
participate uh this the icons then are
windows of energetic realities of Heaven
in which that you participate in as you
said you don't just uh decipher it like
a coat it's a it's a living reality even
though it's just a piece of wood with
paint on it and so this participation is
this mystery of Orthodoxy that I think
is what's so beautiful it's not this
overly Scholastic uh propositional
understanding it's not um just a sort of
bland lack of aesthetic due to the fear
of idolatry it's it's again it's
bringing all these tensions together and
allowing you to participate in these
realities and that is then becoming a
living icon is the fold
of day after day after day choosing to
participate in this and hopefully God
willing in yourself you then can be a as
as Abbott Treon says uh an an angels
unaware you can be somebody in
somebody's life say it's the the man
who's disheveled and and smells and
comes into the church that you are now
in a position to actually be another
window for somebody into the kingdom and
that's the goal of all of us and that I
think that that's it's subtle but it's a
different emphasis than maybe you get in
other flavors of Christianity because
it's not so
participatory I think I think your point
is right and father tribo your point
about the wedding reading I think is a
great way to help people understand
sacramental reality when they're not
used to it right and you can you can
reduce it to very simple things like a
good I try to Define this the most the
simple example like a handshake right a
handshake is a ritual right a handshake
is a means a handshake is all these
things but you know you still tell your
child like here's how you shake your
hand right this is have a firm handshake
don't just flop you know hold the hand
not too long like you the the child has
to learn to shake the a hand properly
and but the purpose is not the handshake
obviously just like the purpose is not
the wedding ring and also the purpose is
not this piece of wood with paint in it
the purpose is that which we see through
and so and we're used to it because now
once you internalize it and you shake
someone's hand you're not thinking about
the handshake at all right you're seeing
through the handshake to the person that
you're encountering and seeing it as a
method to greet and to enter into
communion with them it's the same with a
kiss it's the same with all these
gestures and the icon is the same it's
like you know when you when we encounter
the icons we are see them as means of
encountering the Saints of of of of
remembering them of of bringing them to
mind bringing them into prayer and and
and and asking them to pray for us and
that becomes As Natural as a handshake
once you have kind of entered into that
life but like you said father turbo if
you just kind of sit at home online and
you like interpret icons like I'm I've
interpret icons more than anybody right
like I spent a lot of time interpreting
icons but obviously the point is
ultimately for them to become vehicles
for for our participation in the life of
the of Christ that's right I mean I
think one of the best ways to understand
it and and especially I really hope that
this helps a lot of people people kind
of get some over some of those hurdles
of barriers of entry and that they don't
worry about what people think or
whatever and they just want to approach
God right and this is what I mean by
this all this is necessary in so far as
it becomes
tacid
because that's the that's the space in
which you begin to really get it and you
get into it for
instance your example about the driving
about the um handshakes perfect let's do
another one driving a car
right you know my I I had first day of
school today my 16-year-old he's said
can I drive dad sure right and you know
he's taking turns too wide you know all
the stuff all stuff and
um it's not pass it yet he's still
thinking has totally like ENT it's like
okay break distance right and then
there's going to come a point when it
becomes Tas and what's interesting is
the more all of those parts are tacd the
better of a driver he'll be right it's
like more he forgets what he has to do
the better of a driver he'll be it's the
same thing as you come into the
church the more that you forget these
things that you it's it's not forgetting
them forgive me that's absolutely the
wrong word forgive me well yeah well not
not putting your attention on the means
that's the right way to it's right
forgive me strike that from the record
it's not forgetting it's the more that
you internalize yeah there you go the
more that you internalize these things
the more that the remembrance is
constant you're present it's there you
don't have to take the energy to recall
right yes because here here's the thing
there's people who are living in the
Liturgy all the time the animis is
happening from them all the time they
it's not that they've transcended it but
they've they've internalized it so much
there's no need for the recall right
they are they are in it and then when
they're actually in those very explicit
moments it just shoots them up another
level if I could use that language but
it's it's tcid and so that's the thing
is you get to this place where the
remembrance of the Saints prayers I mean
that's that's one of the purposes of the
quote unquote practice of the Jesus
prayer is that it becomes this tcid
thing that is so you
know you've em bibed it to such a degree
right this is this is the key thing to
understand but you have to go through
that process of understanding so I'm not
not disdaining or denigrating that
process of learning at all I'm just
saying that because of our culture the
emphasis is so much on it because of our
tendency for control and for we our want
of power our want of security um and
that's what keeps us wanting to stay in
this very kind of Scholastic mode
because it's like if I'm approaching
everything through this kind of
Zoological framework I'm the master
right but like love Zoological it's like
got to be able to name everything gota
understand everything that's going on
before I ever engage you know yeah yeah
and and ultimately here's the thing you
hit these you you know if you come to
the church it's maybe two years maybe 12
years whatever but you hit a hump you
hit this kind of flat point in this
plateau and then you can often say to
yourself okay I'm just kind of like
going to the Motions so is it tacd now
okay sure but like here's the
thing that's where getting back to what
we talking about earlier some of the
dark parts of the Mosaic become
important the dark parts of the Mosaic
are death horror you know um seeing the
reality of of the Fallen World for what
it is in the Light of Christ right not
not needing to you know put a um a false
lens on seeing it for what it is if you
embibe all these things then what
happens is it's not so much that you
become a window to the disheveled guy
who's smelly but actually he becomes the
window for you right and that's the
thing he becomes the window for you
because one of the problems for us is
that we get a sense of I got it and
things are tcid let's say and then you
do begin to Plateau but you're
plateauing not because God isn't giving
you anything but because and you you
have hit this place of your own glass
ceiling
of experience and understanding you it
it becomes self-sufficient supposedly Y
and what happens is God then has to
really kind of put he has to turn
everything upside down to wake you up he
has to use you know the car accident the
disheveled beggar um whatever thing to
like bring you out of this place where
you thought okay I'm good I'm clean I
got all the boxes checked everyone looks
to me as whatever it's like no like
that's nice but here's another level and
that level then becomes and that's where
the cross now becomes a whole another
thing for you right because it takes on
a different understanding and you begin
to now move in what you've already been
doing in a different way because I think
this is the
thing my son he'll become more more you
know it becomes tacid he'll become a
better driver blah blah blah and he'll
enjoy that for a long time but there
will come a point God willing where the
driving now takes on another meaning for
him and that meaning is going to be
about transporting his siblings right or
transporting his own kids one day and
it's gonna
change everything and things that
he was maybe able to do maybe at some
point he's able to do some donuts in the
parking lot and got some good control
that's great but something's going to
want him to move beyond that and to not
flex and to not show off and I think
think this is key
because God again hasn't forgotten him
and God says okay son there's still more
there's there's there's still more to
enter into right and that's why you need
to learn this stuff and allow it to
become everyday life that's why prayer
rules and the mundane are are are are
valuable right because you don't become
Adept at something quote unquote by
entering into it in this in this
um
it only happens when it becomes a part
of your life intentionally and and that
takes work you know what I mean so yeah
and to sum up the conversation I think
this aesthetic dimension of Orthodox is
one of the most important that speaks to
the Contemporary world because I would
say most people are feeling the world's
getting less and less beautiful and many
many regards and the church allows us to
see what beautiful behavior is how in a
new context for beauty his father was
speaking you know somebody may think
that the beautiful picture is everybody
dressed nice at liturgy sitting in
standing in the right places but it
could be the homeless man it can be the
the UN beautiful in conjunction the both
and that from an orthodox perspective is
more beautiful that that the bringing
together of all these things together in
the worship of God that is more
beautiful than everybody wearing the
right pet colors and standing in that's
almost too contrived and that's not
reality but keeping the tensions between
things and beauty doesn't necessitate
you know large rational understandings
of our theology uh it it doesn't demand
uh complicated explanations for correct
Behavior utilitarianism deontological
ethics virtue ethics anybody can engage
with beauty and for me coming out of the
new age and the Psychedelic and the
Occult it was the beauty that felt so
comfortable because it's one of the
things I liked about the Visionary art
and all the colors and all the all the
pictures and all the uh Aesthetics well
Orthodoxy has that but it's so much
deeper and so it offers a I think a
really great entry point for people that
you don't have to know the intricacies
of the energy Essence distinction or
iconography to see oh wow this is really
beautiful there's something here and I
want to engage more in that in in in our
worldview so mystical and it's so
participatory that as Jonathan and you
said it calls people in and I think uh I
think this aesthetic Dimension is one of
the most important things that the
Orthodox Church can offer to especially
the Contemporary Western World yeah oh I
think it's a great place to to end I
think we we had a it was great to meet
you father turbo finally you know after
all this time I'm really happy first
conversation and David thanks for for
hosting us and and and kind of prompting
the conversation it was it was great to
talk to both of you and hopefully we'll
be able to do that again well thank you
Jonathan for having us we really
appreciate it and God bless you and all
the work you're doing thank you so much
thank you so much this is great I want
to invite you all to the very first
symbolic World Summit over 3 days we
will finally meet in real time in real
space and everyone from this little
corner of the internet will be there to
explore the theme of reclaiming the
cosmic image of course I will be
speaking but there will also be Martin
Shaw who is an amazing mythographer
father Steven D young of Lord of spirit
Fame there will be Richard Roland from
the universal history series Vesper
Stamper Nicholas kotar and Neil de grade
that you've all seen on my channel here
and there for entertainment we have
everyone's favorite apocalyptic band The
One and Only dirt po Robins this event
will be the chance of a lifetime to
capture and embrace our current moment
so join us from February 29th to March
2nd 2024 in Tarpon spings Florida visit
the symbolic
world.com Summit for more information I
will see you
there
the wings and bodies of our God